simplify the rational expression and
state the domain let's see if we can
start with the domain part of the
question if we can start with stating
the domain now the domain is the set of
all of the X values that you can
legitimately input into this if you view
this as a function if you said this is f
of X is equal to that the domain is a
set of all X values that you could input
into this function and get something
that is well defined now the one x value
that would make this undefined is the x
value that would make the denominator
equal zero the x value that would make
that equal to zero so when does that
happen six minus x is equal to zero
let's add X to both sides and we get six
is equal to X so the domain of this
function the domain of this function is
equal to the set of all real numbers all
real numbers except except six so X
could be all real numbers except six
because if X is six then you are
dividing by zero and then this
expression is undefined so we've got the
we've stated the domain now let's do the
simplifying the rational expression so
let me rewrite it over here
we have x squared minus 36 over six
minus X now this might jump out at you
immediately as it's that special type of
binomials of the form a squared minus B
squared and we've seen this multiple
times this is equivalent to a plus B
times a minus B and in this case a is X
and B is six so this top expression
right here can be factored as X plus 6
times X minus 6 all of that over six
minus X now at first you might say well
look you know I have a X minus 6 and a 6
minus X those aren't quite equal but
what maybe will jump out at you is that
these are the negatives of each other
try it out multiply let's multiply let's
multiply by negative one and then by
negative one again think of it that way
so if I multiply by
negative 1 times negative 1 obviously
I'm just multiplying the numerator by
one so I'm not in any way changing the
numerator but what happens if we just
multiply the X minus 6 by that first
negative one what happens to that X
minus 6 so let me rewrite the whole
expression we have X plus 6 we have X
plus 6 and I'm going to distribute this
negative 1 if I distribute the negative
1 I have negative 1 times X is negative
x negative 1 times negative 6 is plus 6
and then I have a negative 1 out here
and I have a negative 1 times negative 1
and then it's all all of that is over 6
minus X now negative x plus 6 this is
this exact same thing as 6 minus X if
you just rearrange the two terms
negative X plus 6 is the same thing as 6
plus negative x or 6 minus X so now you
could cancel them out 6 minus X divided
by 6 minus X and all you're left with is
a negative 1 I'll write it out front all
you're left with this is negative 1
times X plus 6 and if you want you can
distribute it and you would get negative
X minus 6
that's the simplified rational
expression in general you don't have to
go through this exercise of multiplying
by negative 1 and negative 1 you should
always be able to recognize that if you
have a minus b over b minus a that that
is equal to negative 1 or think of it
this way a minus b is equal to the
negative of B minus a if you distribute
this negative sign you get negative B
plus a which is exactly what this is
over here but we're all done